For a single route
example, our problem
is to find the optimal
number of discount seats
and regular seats to
sell to maximize revenue.
We'll assume that the price
of regular seats is $617,
and the price of
discount seats is $238.
Also, let's assume
that we forecasted
the demand of regular
seats to be 100,
and the demand of
discount seats to be 150.
The capacity of our
airplane is 166 seats.
Let's go ahead and formulate
this mathematically
as a linear
optimization problem.
The first step is to decide
what our decisions are,
or the variables in our model.
We need to decide how many
regular seats we went to sell.
We'll call the number
of regular seats
we sell R. We also need to
decide the number of discount
seats we want to sell.
We'll call the number of
discount seats we sell D.
The second step
is to decide what
our objective, or our goal, is.
In this case, it's to
maximize the total revenue
to the airline.
The revenue from
each type of seat
is equal to the number
of that type of seat
sold times the seat price.
In the case of
regular seats, this
is $617 times R, the number
of regular seats we sell.
And for discount seats,
this is $230 times D,
the number of discount
seats we sell.
We sum these together to
get the total revenue,
and our objective is
to maximize this sum.
The third step is to define
the constraints, or limits,
of our decisions.
One constraint is that American
Airlines can't sell more seats
than the aircraft capacity,
which is 166 seats.
So the total number of seats
sold, R + D has to be less than
or equal to the capacity of 166.
Additionally, American Airlines
shouldn't sell more seats
than the demand for
each type of seat.
So the regular seats,
R, shouldn't exceed 100.
So R should be less
than or equal to 100.
And the discount seats,
D, can't exceed 150.
So D should be less
than or equal to 150.
The final step is to make
sure our variables are
taking reasonable values.
In this case, it
wouldn't make sense
to sell a negative
number of seats,
so we need to make sure
that both R and D are
greater than or equal to 0.
So our entire problem is to
maximize total airline revenue,
subject to the constraints
that seats sold can't exceed
capacity, seats sold
can't exceed demand,
and the seats sold
can't be negative.
Mathematically, this can be
written as maximize 617*R +
238*D, the total revenue,
subject to the constraints:
R + D is less than or equal to
166, the capacity constraint;
R less than or equal to 100,
and D less than or equal to 150,
which are the
demand constraints;
and R and D are both
greater than or equal to 0.
This is called a linear
optimization problem.
In the next video, we'll see
how to solve this problem using
the software, LibreOffice.